doing the podcast is my ICA guy and so I
would just do more of that and for
anyone that doesn't know what Ika guy is
it's a sort of Japanese phrase for when
you find the thing that kind of provides
you with the most fulfillment in life
when it meets these four criteria the
first one is something you believe you
can be good at the second one is
something that pays you the third one is
something you enjoy and the fourth one
is something that you believe is of
service to others now doing the podcast
is the first thing I've done in my life
that really feels like that it feels
like it completes the Ika guy so if you
gave me 500 million and I had none of
these other things going on in my life I
would do more of that